es el fin de una de las etapas más
complejas de la historia la Organización
Mundial de la Salud en voz de su
director terminó con la emergencia
sanitaria declarada por la pandemia del
covid
en tres años el covid ha puesto nuestro
mundo patas arriba la OMS ha informado
de casi 7 millones de muertes
Pero sabemos que el número de víctimas
es mucho mayor al menos 20 millones de
muertes
la decisión a decir de Jesús no fue
tomada de forma apresurada sin embargo
Aunque ya no represente una emergencia
se debe estar alerta
este virus llegó para quedarse continúa
matando
y es posible que surjan nuevas variantes
y provoquen un mayor aumento en el
número de casos y muertes
Y aunque no fueron pocas las lecciones
aprendidas realmente el mundo está
preparado para vivir de nuevo una
situación similar
el mundo no está preparado el mundo
necesita hacer muchos mucho más esfuerzo
para estar preparado y e invertir en
mayor grado todos los países del orbe
pero yo creo que esto es algo que tiene
que ser discutido en los ámbitos de la
asamblea general de las Naciones Unidas
de la asamblea Mundial de la Salud tener
un esfuerzo multilateral la emergencia
sanitaria inició el 30 de enero de 2020
la desaceleración de la tasa de
mortalidad por el virus es también
notable de 100.000 personas que
fallecían semanalmente en enero de 2021
descendió a unos 3500 según datos de la
OMS registrados hasta el mes de abril de
este año